how are you doing today sir Gracie who's
that on your shirt he looks Vaguely
Familiar I
might have worn this for you I figured
you'd get a kick out of it
um
listen man I am a big fan of your work
and uh I like throwing a curveball at
the beginning you've done so many cool
things in your career
um if someone has actually never seen
anything you've done what is the first
thing you'd like them watching and why
oh I'd say God
even though you say rocky but I think
First Blood
like that'd be an introduction because
you you cover a lot of bases in that one
and it's also a great movie yeah thank
you there is that right
um I'm curious uh
everything Taylor touches turns to gold
and I'm curious when you signed on for
this did you and Taylor talk about hey
this could go for multiple seasons is
that something that you're interested in
yeah we did we did touch on that because
the idea is to do something I'm a big
believer since I started my career I
like sequels I think that if you build a
character why have them disappear like
like say The Godfather Michael you want
to see him move on and
I want the same thing with this but the
one aspect that we added
in his original concept which is great
you know gangster Goes West it was a
little more serious you know a little
tougher and I thought if I could throw
in
my personality like because it's a
little off center at times little you're
Reverend that you have a gangster who's
not incredibly threatening I mean he can
be he can go gangster on you but then
again it can be silly and do jokes and
you know kind of
um
Embrace other people as a instead of
threatening them he goes like ah he's a
gatherer he's a he's a guy that
coordinates people together he he sets
up his own kind of it's a paradigm his
own periphery of allies instead of
alienating people even though you know
they're the one's a computer nerd one
sells weed one is this guy one is a
cowboy eventually you see Indians
everyone but an Italian you were
obviously a very talented writer
director when you're working with
someone like Taylor where the scripts
are obviously and Terence winter uh when
the scripts are obviously good are you
ever tweaking anything in part two are
you thinking about if you get to do a
second season uh directing any episodes
yeah I was going to direct the first
episode for sure and I I spoke primarily
with Taylor uh with Taylor but more more
of a Terry I say look I understand what
you're trying to convey here but quite
often I have to put it in my own words
it helps me memorize it but also there's
a certain Cadence that everyone has like
your occasions is different than my
Cadence so you can write better for
yourself than I can write if you have
that ability you know you just know how
what words what vowels what continents
consonants to use and so on and so forth
and that happened so when you see some
of these little ad-libs in the sides
that to me is what makes it uh
it just it just seems spontaneous rather
than overly rehearsed on that note I
need to stop I do hope you're directing
an episode in season two and again big
fan of your work thank you for your time